all right what's going on guys this is
rob and there's apparently been a
massive leak that came out for things
that are going to take place at san
diego comic con which i'm really excited
about we've got press passes we're going
to be in hall h i'm very very hyped
about this for marvel studios we're
actually setting up a schedule and
everything so that we're all kind of
splitting off and we're going to all
this different stuff so by the time it's
over we should be able to bring you all
a whole bunch of really cool content or
at least my staff will i'll be in cancun
after san diego comic con is over so
here's the thing
here's the thing there's this leak that
came out right and here's one of the
things about this it doesn't really come
from like a definitive place it's not
like it was leaked by specifically
daniel rpk it seems like it's one of
these where somebody somewhere leaked it
and then everybody picked it up and so
it's one of these where you kind of take
it with uh with a with a grain of salt
it may be true maybe not true and that
only time will really tell so first
things first on this list deadpool 3. so
what this says is that ryan reynolds
will be in attendance to announce the
next deadpool movie which is not going
to be titled deadpool 3 and director
sean levy or levi will send in a video
now here's a cool thing and i've kind of
been wondering about this for a while
how's deadpool 3 going to work right i
mean i imagine that if this really does
happen in hall h that we'll get to see
like a pretty solid preview right or at
the very least we'll get a lot more
information regarding how it's going to
for how it's going to fit into the mcu
honestly what i'm hoping they do is
something akin to like what christopher
priest did when he originally rolled
deadpool over so those guys don't know
you don't know what that means and i
feel like it doesn't have to be adapted
and you really can't adapt it one for
one in this way from the comics to the
movies but you can adapt the general
concept and then throw it in there so
one of the things to know is that when
rob liefeld originally introduced
deadpool back in the early 1990s and new
mutants issue number 98 he was a super
serious character right he was like kind
of your died in the wool characters as
they existed at the time the comedic
deadpool didn't really come along until
joe kelly and ed mcginnis were handling
the comic in like 1998 but even then he
was still relatively serious and had a
couple of dark moments and broke like
the uh really dark hero moments and
broke the fourth wall like twice and
that was basically it it wasn't until
marvel was going to cancel it and they
sent it off to christopher priest which
was really the guy you sent comics to
back in the 90s if you wanted to get rid
of him it had been that way for a time
for like a long time and that's an
important thing because when christopher
priest wrote the comic he basically made
a meta commentary on himself where like
deadpool enters this trailer park and
like goes to his trailer and it's all
the characters that have been written
out by christopher priest all the
characters whose stories were cancelled
and the deadpool was like nope that's
not going to happen and he left and
jumped into a puddle in the trailer park
and woke up in the story right so it was
a really great meta commentary and and
that set the stage for how christopher
priest was going to handle deadpool
because following that deadpool as you
know him now breaking the fourth wall
all the time and all that kind of stuff
that was not gail simone and it wasn't
any of those guys right it was basically
the entirety of christopher priest that
made deadpool that way that's why i
always tell people if you want to know
where modern day deadpool started the
christopher priest run is where you want
to start now again they don't have to
adapt that exact kind of intro to the
mcu but i would love to see like a
comedic introduction of deadpool into
the marvel cinematic universe and
possibly even poking fun at like the fox
universe or even if the mcu is brave
enough poking fun at a few things of the
mcu because i feel like that's really
where deadpool would shine in the marvel
cinematic universe is if he's done in a
way to where he can kind of be our voice
like well wait a minute that didn't make
any sense you guys remember that moment
from like thor or something like that
where he's like why is thor so funny all
the time like he's not even really that
funny at all thor's supposed to be
serious go back to being serious man but
like deadpool is essentially a meta
commentary on the other movies that
we've seen in the mcu and some of the
gripes that we have as like viewers
right like okay like i'm kind of getting
bored of this that's not as funny as
they thought it would be just that kind
of a thing and i feel like that would
really resonate pretty strongly with the
character of deadpool and fit in with
him perfectly so moving on right we get
black panther news now supposedly ryan
coogler and the cast of black panther
will be present and they'll bring the
first trailer for black panther wakanda
forever so if this is true expect
trailer leaks on youtube during san
diego comic-con right you'll probably
end up seeing somebody with a smartphone
that's literally recording the trailer
and then they're going to throw it up
right if this is true expect that right
that will probably be there now how
extensive that's going to be i'm not
entirely sure when they say first
trailer assuming this leak is true i
would expect more of a teaser for black
panther wakanda forever i think that the
first trailer is going to really be like
a world premiere we might see it at san
diego and they have a history of doing
that but black panther wakanda forever
is a big enough thing that if they were
to do that it would be designed for the
sole purpose of drumming up interest
meaning the actual world premiere of the
trailer would drop shortly after because
it wouldn't make any sense to drop the
trailer during san diego have all that
interest and all that excitement for
when everybody was like hey man the
trailer premiered to san diego it was
awesome it was badass and then they
don't drop the actual trailer for like
another two or three months i don't
really see that being the case the other
reason why i don't see that being the
case is because the movie literally
comes out in november and we're in and
for those of you guys who are familiar
you can usually track the release of
trailers with some degree of certainty
to about a five to six month period out
from the release of the film and we're
about there by the time san diego
happens we'll be about five months out
from the release of the film which means
it's around that time when the trailer
is supposed to drop so i wouldn't be
surprised if the trailer drops during
san diego comic con and then that monday
or tuesday following san diego the world
premiere of the trailer goes out because
that's when i think conversation
discussion and excitement will have
reached a fever pitch and everybody will
have wanted to see the trailer so having
said that there really isn't a whole lot
doing with secret invasion there is a
mention here as far as the leak
apparently nobody will be in attendance
for secret invasion but they will reveal
the main cast and share a little bit of
footage honestly i'm not too surprised
by that if i'm being honest with you
guys secret invasion kind of feels like
the marvel tv show that's just sort of
operating under the radar there's no
real build up for it there's no real
excitement for it right there's nothing
on the same level as like one division
loki hawkeye or anything like that you
know by all standards of measurement at
least as far as marketing goes it's just
a show that exists that will come out at
some point in time i don't know if
that's the intention i don't know if
marvel and disney are focusing more on
the immediate projects or if it's one of
those things well they're just kind of
like we're not really expecting the show
to do that well but we already committed
to it and we've already got the money
for it and we already made it so we
might as well just kind of go forward or
at least already in the process of
making it i don't know if they finished
it yet but you know we're just kind of
kind of letting it go forward and do its
thing but having said that the next cool
thing here and i feel like this is going
to be a big talking point is blade so
apparently mahershala ali kit harrington
aaron pierce milan ray and uh boston
tariq i think is how you pronounce his
name we'll all be in attendance for some
news now there's no indication here
assuming again that this leak is true
which we don't know if it is there's no
indication here that there will actually
be any kind of a trailer that will drop
if you have the whole members of the
cast that are here it's a little too
early for the dropping of a trailer but
they might have some kind of like early
footage or something like that but
apparently one big piece of news that's
going to drop during san diego is that
anthony starr is going to be playing
dracula now if that's true that's
amazing now for those of you guys who
don't know of course anthony star plays
homelander in the boys honestly he's
perfectly suited to play the role of
dracula like i think he is perfectly
suited for that he looks the part right
just seeing like his eyes glowing red
and the boys tv series when he was using
his heat vision i think it's a cool idea
honestly i think there are characters
that anthony starr could play that would
be better than dracula but i think it's
a great choice for dracula so moving on
here again not necessarily knowing if
this leak is absolutely true there are a
couple of announcements or at least a
couple things in this leak that i'm not
entirely sure i agree with the first one
is the marvels so what this tells us at
least what this leaks says anyway is
that basically the cast of the marvels
will be there minus zahway ashton who
won't be there because of her pregnancy
and that anson mount is going to reprise
his role as black bolt jody turner smith
is going to join as medusa in the post
credits of the movie and it's going to
set up the universal and humans as a big
cosmic story going forward
i think that's ridiculous and it's
stupid the inhumans suck there's no i
mean okay you know what let me take that
back and i know a lot of you guys who
are just like wait wait you know record
skip what okay look here's the thing the
concept of the universal in humans was
really cool that was really cool and
jonathan hickman's fantastic four
the inhumans themselves i don't like
them i don't find them interesting
fascinating or anything and i don't
really understand why you would set up
the universal and humans as a cosmic
story going forward having said that the
marvel is the best place to do it if
you're going to do that and here's the
reason why those guys who don't know
anything about the inhumans the inhumans
were a universal project so the idea
behind the the universal and humans and
the way that the supreme intelligence
had formed this project is that in order
to expand the kree empire and basically
solidify its ability to conquer other
races what they did is they genetically
modified cree so that at some point in
time when they were exposed to the
terrigen mist that they would take on
the form of basically another group that
existed out there right some alien race
or something like that they could
infiltrate that alien race and then
because of the fact that they would
develop powers as a result of their
exposure to the terrorist miss they
would be able to subvert that empire
from within and basically begin the
process of bringing it down and then
when that happened it would make it
easier for the cree race to basically
conquer it and the idea was to do that
across the entirety of the universe the
problem here is the supreme intelligence
shortly after the creation of the
universal and human project came to the
realization that there was a kind of
prophecy out there that one of those
inhuman groups would lead to the
destruction of the cree and so what the
supreme intelligence did is he ordered
the accuser corps to annihilate all the
uh universal and human projects and the
only one that survived were the inhumans
on earth right that's why they're so
significant in relation to the cree
having said that who cares man i have no
desire to see the inhumans in any
capacity in the marvel cinematic
universe now maybe this will change my
mind but if i'm being honest with you
guys bringing in black bold and the
universal and human storyline i think is
a poor decision and i think a much
better choice to have done here would
have would have been to bring in adam
bashir the blue marvel i think that
would have been the much better choice
here because he's got an amazing history
it's fascinating it's tangible it
resonates with the real world you know i
think it would it would it's a
phenomenal story right it's an absolute
it's like one of the best origin stories
in my opinion the best origin story in
the entirety of marvel comics i love
blue marvel now we might see adam
brosher in marvel's we may actually see
him there i'm not really certain that we
will but it would be cool if we did but
having said that that may not
necessarily be the case the marvels as
it is as it looks right now the entire
cast right you got iman you got tiana
all these characters it looks like
marvel's version of a force or like lady
liberators a woman-centric team which i
have no qualms with and honestly i think
it's cool and i'm interested in that
aspect of it but i think that like blue
marvel one of the most significant
characters in modern history and marvel
comics i think if ever there were a time
to have him in this movie this would
have been it and i feel like it it's
just it's uh or at least have him in the
mcu this would have been a great time to
do it and i feel like it's a hugely
missed opportunity but nonetheless right
i want to turn this into a gripe session
so moving on this is the second one the
other one that i really disagree with
world war hulk so apparently according
to this leak world war hulk was going to
be a movie but it's now being turned
into a four-part series for disney plus
that may have a small theatrical release
and this could possibly be the big
avengers event that's set before secret
wars with a bunch of big characters i do
not believe world war hulk should be a
disney plus series i firmly believe this
needs to be a movie and the reason why
i'm really making a two-part movie and
the reason why is because world war hulk
was a big enough event that you could
pull that off it was a big enough event
and the incredible hulk is a big enough
name draw honestly i think this is one
of those instances where really coming
off the interview of the russo brothers
where they said that they depowered the
incredible hulk as professor holt
because they didn't know what to do with
him i think this is a perfect example of
that in the marvel cinematic universe
that the reality here is i'm not sure
they fully understand why people like
the hulk look here's the thing i've been
reading comics for decades or years and
years and years or years there's all
kinds of runs on the incredible hulk
you've got the bill mantlo peter david
run which was more of like a kind of a
breakdown and an introspective look in
terms of the fact that the incredible
hulk is like the result of bruce
banner's abuse to the hands of his
father brian all that kind of stuff let
me tell you something the most
successful incredible hulk runs out
there are the runs where he's just
smashing because that's what people want
to see people want to see the incredible
hulk just break stuff right like that's
all they want to see they still want to
see him break things and smash things
and be really pissed off and if they
released a movie well they're like hey
guys here's a two-part movie where the
incredible hulk is gonna be as pissed
off as he's ever been and pretty much no
one's gonna be able to stop him that's
gonna draw a lot of money people are
gonna go see that movie
lots and lots of people it's gonna break
a billion dollars i can guarantee you
i can guarantee you it's gonna break a
billion dollars uh having said that what
i think is is going on here in this
instance is the marvel cinematic
universe and disney are looking at the
incredible hulk and they're not entirely
sure he's bankable and honestly i think
that is their perception of the
incredible hulk coming out of the events
of like infinity war and avengers
in-game with like the professor hulk but
honestly it's them engineering a
circumstance that depicted the
incredible hulk in a very poor way and
then using people's reception to that
poor depiction of the incredible hulk as
a reason for why they don't think the
incredible hulk is bankable if that's
truly the case honestly the incredible
hulk is a bankable character the
incredible hulk is a character that will
draw money you just have to do it the
right way then having us having a film
or a couple films with the incredible
hulk just [ __ ] everything up that's a
great movie like just beating the crap
out of everybody
repeatedly
right and that's the thing the
incredible whole those you guys don't
know in world war hulk you're not going
to see like a super emotional incredible
hulk you're going to see a methodical
incredible hulk like imagine professor
hulk if he was just really really angry
but he was so pissed off he was calm
that's the kind of incredible hulk that
you would be seeing but what you would
be seeing him do is crushing people and
like imagine like you would see a
circumstance where thor would show up
and and like literally world war hulk
would crush him like that like it
wouldn't even be close it would not even
be close like that's what you're talking
about here so how you create that into a
movie i'm not entirely sure but that's
literally their job but i think turning
it into a disney plus show is a bit of a
miscalculation i don't think that's the
best decision to make having said that
and we move on here guardians of the
galaxy 3 which i think is the big thing
that people really want to see after
thor so guarding the galaxy 3 according
to this leak again assuming it's true a
majority of the cast will be in
attendance and they will show some
footage if i'm a betting man i'd bet all
the money in my pockets to all the money
in your pockets they're going to show us
adam warlock because i'm not entirely
sure there's anything they can really
show us in guardians of the galaxy 3
that we don't suspect or that we
wouldn't see coming outside of adam
warlock and to be honest with you guys i
think adam is the big draw that's the
reason so many of us are going to see
guardians of the galaxy 3 is because we
want to see adam warlock i know for me
that's the case i've been wanting to see
adam ever since guardians 2. and i feel
like he maybe could have appeared a
couple post-credits scenes especially in
the aftermath of avengers end game half
the population of the universe
disappearing like suddenly like somebody
like what is it one of the one of the
sovereign just hits the panic button and
just adam warlock emerges from his
cocoon something along those lines like
whatever the case happens to be i think
that there were a couple post credit
scenes that we could have seen that were
potential missed opportunities but i
think a lot of that was because they
hadn't had him casted by that point they
hadn't had his character fleshed out
they didn't even know exactly how he was
going to look right so it's kind of hard
to throw a character in a post-credits
scene when you literally haven't
designed them yet
so you know we kind of had to wait on
that so i'm not really complaining i'm
just saying like i think that's
something that we you know it would have
been cool to see having said that i
think we'll definitely see adam warlock
during uh during san diego if this leak
is true and i think that'll be the big
talking point everybody's going to be
talking about adam warlock now moving on
i think this is the one like for me i
think guardians 3 is a big one i think
for a lot of people there's a big one
this is the one that i think most people
want to see this i think if if anything
comes out of of san diego is like the
big talking point it'll be this one and
it'll be one other one right so this one
here ant-man and the wasp quantum mania
that what this leak says is that we'll
see some footage with actors rudd lily
and newton present and that jonathan
majors will send in a video as king the
conqueror which means if this video is
sent in and is in character meaning it's
not just him like you guys remember like
when james gunn did that video where he
was like i'm actually moving up the
release of guardians to you know like
you guys remember that you know that
like not like that where like literally
jonathan majors just has his makeup on
and he looks like kang but it's
obviously majors just talking like
majors right if this is one of those
videos where like he's in character and
he's like i'm coming for all of you or
something like that it'll be our first
look at jonathan majors as kang and i
got to tell you guys i am hyped oh my
god i am so hyped to see jonathan majors
is kang even if it's only for like 30
seconds right just a 30 second thing i'm
so excited to see what he looks like as
king because jonathan majors was just a
great choice for that role so having
said that the the second to last one
here right wonder man
not really too concerned about wonder
man to be honest with you guys right
that this will be announced with henry
golding as simon williams uh an
interesting detail is that evan peters
is apparently returning as ralph boehner
but may have a new name will likely be a
side character in the show not really
sure how all that's going to play out
don't really know how that's going to
work honestly with wonder man i mean i
can't say i'm against it but i can't say
i'm for it i'm just i'm lukewarm to it
you know but that's because really
wonder man was never a character in the
comics that really interested me all
that much having said that i am going to
watch the show but i'm not going to skip
over it like i am going to watch the
wonder man show because it could win me
over right i mean one of the things you
remember when when marvel studios first
launched and they made the iron man film
they had to convince people that iron
man was not a robot people were just
like i'm yes weird but they warmed
people up to him and now the mcu is
where it is now i mean as soon as robert
downey jr popped up as tony stark people
were just like done right they were one
over that was it right people were
people were in that movie for half an
hour and they were just like this is a
winner and they they stuck with the mcu
ever since right so it could be one of
those things where wonder man just wins
me over right it really kind of depends
but here's the here's the last one and i
think honestly outside of ant-man and
wasp quantomania this will be the big
talking point right
daredevil the man without fear that
apparently this will be announced with
charlie cox starring along with isa or
isaac gonzalez as elektra now i find it
interesting that they're bringing
elektra back and it's kind of funny
because this seems to fly in the face of
a lot of the rumors that we've heard
right we know that apparently kingpin is
going to come back you know like there's
a lot of appearances that are expected
in this show but i don't know if it
necessarily does conflict it's one thing
to say kingpin will return and he will
be in the new daredevil man without fear
show it's another to say he's going to
be the main villain the reality here is
we know from kevin feige and all them
the other other seasons of daredevil
from netflix are incontinuity you know
so we know that like kingpin already had
his his time as the villain it was the
whole of season one and partially season
two to be honest with you guys so i
don't really think kingpin needs to come
back as a villain per se that being said
i don't think elektra does either if i'm
being honest with you guys i would much
rather have seen them turn this show
into shadowland to be quite frank right
i would rather they have done like the
shadowland event as the first opening as
the opening salvo for the disney plus
daredevil show especially coming off of
everything else because once daredevil
launches the netflix episodes are on or
you know on disney plus right that's
happening right that's the thing it's
already there so you can just get caught
up the hand already exists the stage is
set for shadowland there wasn't a whole
lot of the mysticism there right the
great beast and so on and so forth
that's not necessarily there so how you
explain daredevil being possessed by the
demonic beast that leads the hand i'm
not entirely sure but it's the mcu you
don't have to you can just have one of
those things where it's like wolverine
enemy of the state where he's just
brainwashed taken by the hand he's
brainwashed and then becomes the leader
of the hand and they've got to like save
him or something like that i mean that
plot is just thin enough for the mcu but
just complicated enough and interesting
enough that it would keep the casual
movie audience going but have you said
that guys let me know what you think
down in the comments section do you
think these leaks are true do you think
it's like no none of this stuff is true
hopefully it hasn't been debunked by the
time i make this video let me know what
you guys think
and i will catch you all later
peace